information theory encoding theory will
give us a whiteboard box actually I
never gave a slide stock at assignments
so so I'm keeping with the tradition
[ __ ]
yes so this is a joint work with a
student of mine and leisure on rank
unrung mock or at MIT and professor at
MIT Elkin and more so okay so the this
is my only slide for today broadcasting
on bounded degree directed the cyclic
graphs this is the title of the talk my
name is Yuri poliansky I'll give a talk
so okay so let me start with actually
let me start with thinking organizers
for inviting me to assignments so I
spent a fantastic one semester three
years ago here in the program on
information theory and so if you're
watching this online and planning to
spend your sabbatical in Simon's I
definitely recommend this okay so so let
me start with formulating the problem ok
so we will have one bit x0 which is only
1/2 okay so and let me first draw things
and then I will explain what they mean
so we have a directed acyclic graph and
I will call this horizontal stretches
layers so the first layer consists of
two random variables the second layer
maybe consists of
say three so this is X 2 1 X 2 or okay
so so we'll get something here excellent
actually let's make this one like this
a zero alright so so what is happening
here so I'm drawing arrows and each
arrow represents a binary symmetric
channel okay so let me let me zoom in
here let's select some particular node
for example this one right zoom in what
happens inside this inside that inside
this box okay so so what happens inside
the right so let's put it like this so I
have X IJ I have a bunch of arrows
coming in a bunch of arrows coming out
of it and what I want what this
represents is the following picture so
there is some function f IJ which takes
prescribed inputs the inputs coming from
the previous layer and make some
computation right and produces some
output so so this output is X IJ and
then this output gets broadcasted to
some descendants okay so right so what
are these little pluses so these little
pluses are addition of binary symmetric
of binary symmetric noise meaning that
if some number X let's say LM is
connected on the other side of this edge
right and what F IJ sees so X IJ becomes
f IJ of all the inputs but the inputs
get perturbed by the module by the
module of Bernoulli noise right so G is
all all these random variables appearing
here in the noise is they're all iid and
Bernoulli Delta okay so information
terrorists of course call such links
binary symmetric channel okay so all
right so we and yeah so now the
important pieces of notation so the out
is the out degree out degree of width of
a node right and the in is going to be
in degree
oh okay and now so what F IJ is so f IJ
is just a boolean function right one D
in two zero one okay so what is
happening here so so AB it appears at
the root of the of this directed acyclic
graph right and now the bit starts to
traverse this network and every time he
traverses the channel you might get
flipped right and and this functions
which I call processing functions or you
can also call in relay functions right
they look at the inputs and they try to
maybe do something smart right and and
and and so once for example this node
sees the inputs the noisy inputs coming
from this tool other nodes right tries
to do something smart and and output you
know some information down down the
string right okay so so what's the goal
the goal is to come up with oh yeah and
the sizes of the layers are going to be
called LK so L 0 is 1 L 1 is 3 and L 2
is 1 2 3 4 so ok so now given the goal
is the following goal is to try to
reconstruct find the best estimator
maximum likelihood I call it right off
of the root beat right so the goal of
these guys far away from from the root
is to try to guess what's the value of
the original bit right and so of course
as we all know the optimal estimator is
just compute the conditional expectation
the conditional probability right so XK
denotes right so so XK denotes the
vector of all the of all the outputs
I think even at a given layer all right
so okay so and we will say that you know
so there is probability of error right
PE star from decoding atcase layer right
this is just the probability of can you
guys see down down here or should I put
it somewhere put it somewhere up I
wanted to use this for for another okay
so let me just say go
find this ability that the best possible
decoder @k layer this probability of
error right so so we want to minimize
this right and so we will say that if
limit P star okay as K goes to infinity
is less than 1/2 then we say
broadcasting is possible on this grid
okay
and the question is for what grids for
what so right so there are two design
parameters here one design parameter is
the graph the other design parameter is
the processing functions right and the
goal is to be able to come up with such
such graphs and processing functions
that recovery is possible with
probability of error slightly better
than half yes iid the noise is
completely I did low but yes yeah ok so
now of course the most important
question that is in hopefully most of
your heads now is who cares okay so let
me give you examples first
this is one of the problems which I
called toy problems meaning I don't okay
this is recorded so I'm not gonna say
anything
it's important problem yes ok so here's
an example okay special case with the in
degree of every node is one right so
then we get a very simple picture right
example we even consider a regular tree
right so that ok so so this is a famous
problem so so what's the theorem here
okay so well first of all why why did
people solve this okay originally people
in seventies looked at this because this
problem corresponds to solving whether
you can learn the root beat from the
output of the bottom corresponds to
studying properties of the Gibbs measure
for the easing model on a tree and the
externality of certain certain kind of
Gibbs measure corresponding to free
field to free boundary condition that's
the reason people studied there so those
folks that work culminated with the
following theorem
now the it's a little bit murky you know
I never could understand what exactly
the story is but let me tribute it also
to another another paper heavens Kenyon
full month
mm so the second paper references them
and credits them but I think the the
life of this problem really started from
this paper so it became more more
popular so okay so what did they prove
we proved the following beautiful result
they said all right so if 1 minus 2
Delta square so let's let's consider
regular trees right let's say regular
GRE tree out so actually these papers
are more general but let's consider this
ok so if 1 minus 2 Delta Square D is
strictly greater than 1 then
broadcasting is possible
if 1 minus 2 Delta square these is less
than or equal to 1 and impossible ok
very nice characterization well I'll
talk about it in a second ok and now
this problem original as I said was
coming from statistical physics right
and it became more popular oh sorry
1 minutes to load the square it's it's
exact characterization so covers all
cases ok so why it became more popular
for two reasons first of all there is
some connection to reconstruction of
village' netic trees where these are
mutations and the second more modern
reason is that actually this problem
appears in random constraint
satisfaction problems for example in
community detection on because on random
sparse graph right random bounded degree
graph is locally tree like so when you
do some kind of reconstruction you are
you are looking at the situation like
this locally ok so so for this reason
yet this became a very famous in
particularly as I said threshold for
community detection was settled by
application of this theorem ok so this
is one motivation so my motivation came
actually from another from another angle
which is the following so let's consider
another example of graphs which is
regular greens so for example this is a
regular 2-dimensional grid so basic
problem that that that I'm interested in
general in my sort of research life is
how information spreads in networks and
when can it spread and when it cannot
like for example let's consider some
spatial Network even as regular as a two
dimensional grid right and suppose there
is some information
you know entering in the center at time
0 right and then so every time you know
maybe there is some algorithm some
gossip I don't know whatever
what's the other
forgot the name so anyways I'm
distributed algorithm running here
consensus that's right thank you yes so
some distributed algorithm running all
right so that people are doing different
things but the interesting thing is to
bounce sort of right so how much after D
iteration after K iterations let's say
right of that so in the first iteration
information flows through four noisy
links to this neighborhood right we get
so this is my lair so this was my lair
zero my lair one is this one right so
then at the second iteration my
information will flow here so this is
going to be and of course I mean the
functions that that that this guy is
apply right may not be for for
broadcasting but I'm asking right um I'm
over bounding I'm asking the question so
in a given system with a given noise
level right when something happens and I
give you values of everything on the far
away boundary is all information lost or
not right so there is this wave of
information spreading from the center
about this influence at time zero right
and the question is does this wave does
the front of this wave contain any
knowledge about the root right okay so
this is the main question that motivated
me a few years ago so yeah well okay so
we'll talk about this yeah so so here's
the Q's the informal question right so
is it possible
we find F IJ s such that broadcasting is
possible in this okay so since I
probably not going to have time to go
let me not let me just tell you know
it's not the answer sorry the main
conjecture and it's a it's a strange
form of conjecture the conjecture can ii
consisting of two parts okay so here's
the main conjecture in 2d dimensional
grids know in 3d yes so when i say no i
mean that for every positive noise no
matter how small there is no way you can
come up with the arrangement of
functions right such that you can
reconsider you can reconstruct the
original root bit from from knowledge of
the boundary and in 3d maybe yes I mean
that's the conjecture and again I mean I
wouldn't put money like some of my
colleagues like to do on this because
you know the more I work on this the
more 5050 each line here becomes so but
ok but let me write so let me tell you
first okay so so I don't have an answer
to this on the partial answer if I have
time I'll tell you what we can prove so
but for now let's ask a simpler question
right so when I when I talked about this
to Elkin and so he immediately said oh
Yuri so there is one fundamental
difference in this grid compared to the
tree grid okay the first difference is
of course that because in degree is not
one now there is a design question right
what should be the relay functions right
but the second important difference is
the following so so you see this this
characterization has a beautiful
intuition behind it so here's the
intuition information theorists know
that in a certain precise sense when
information passes through a binary
symmetric channel it gets lost by
coefficient 1 minus 2 Delta square right
so so across each edge right so
stars here then only 1 - 2 Delta square
of information jumps out of the output
right ok and so you can see that the
d-r-e tree right replicates this
information d x so on one hand you have
1 - 2 Delta square loss right on the
other hand you have a replication factor
right so if the replication factor beats
the loss right so then on average you're
not losing right and if it's and if it's
not sufficient okay so this one out you
maybe cannot explain the Equality case
here but for strict inequality right
it's sort of it's very natural
actually this intuitive understanding is
not completely useless because you can
convert it into an exact proof using
using this as a settlement the tools
from information theory in particular ok
so right but the important thing from
this intuition is that to overcome this
noise right you have to do some
replication and if you have to do some
replication then you see so the growth
of layers here is what it's D to the K
it's exponential right so if you set D
equals to 1 and okay you don't get any
reconstruction actually this this this
theorem also holds for something called
galton-watson tree in which degree is
not an integer so then average and then
it's two holds so then you can see from
that that only with you can you get
reconstruction only from exponential
explained only for trees with
exponentially growing layers ok so so
then the basic question right which this
is the easy question so all the stuff
about the regular grid as usual super
tough it's you know is very particular
but the stuff that I can actually talk
about in in limited time is is is about
the following question that's a question
is exponential is exponential growth
okay is necessary for broadcasting
or let me phrase it in a equivalent way
or can fi J's fuse information right can
they do information fusion so us to save
space
so we are adding a degree of freedom we
are subtracting a degree of freedom
right the question is okay so we try to
think about it yeah so when could the
saying that the interesting difference
between 2d and 3d is the behavior of
random walk right it's transient versus
recurrent in in two and three dimensions
maybe that's the right analogy as I said
I mean my analogy if I get to that is
more from the cellular automata story if
you you know that there is right there
and undergo the two dimensional cellular
automata but there is no one dimensional
no not got accelerator so yeah tooms yes
because you when you transform from
layer to layer this is a synchronous
update okay but we're going ahead so
okay so the answer to this question is
yes right but before answering it I
wanted to give at least some kind of
proof so what about 15 minutes okay good
so okay so the answer is yes and okay so
before we start there let's ask the
following question so actually how small
how small LK can be
so let's prove the following proposition
if
okay so right and yeah the yeah let's
say so for for for for reasons of again
of analogy with with the of the regular
grid right let's bound the in degree
right so for any dag or a dag in less
than or equal to D and okay less than
some constant shown it depends on Delta
and D log K right if if if layers grows
logarithmically faster slower than a
certain logarithm right then
reconstruction is impossible a
broadcasting sorry
[Applause]
how do you prove this it's a very easy
proof do it okay so um so you see so the
first thing the first step is something
so if you're in information theories you
might not know it but this is mostly a
probability question
so for parabolas that's natural but for
information theories might be less not
sure so here's the funny way to
represent binary symmetric channel right
so so let's suppose you have binary
symmetric channel this over probability
Delta right X enters Y pops out we know
that Y is just flip of X with
probability Delta right so what's smart
can I say here well here is one way to
think about this you say that well Y is
actually equal to X with probability one
minus two Delta and it's equal to
independent Bernoulli 1/2 random
variable with probability two Delta so
so it's a funny way to think binary
symmetric Channel as opposed to doing
flips it does copy versus destruction of
information right and this is so you can
check that this exactly defines the our
beloved binary symmetric channel right
so now here is what you can do you can
take a look at this graph right that I
drew here you can say okay so somebody
gave me a graph right so let me
progenitor
these decisions right so these decisions
whether I'm destroying information or
not right so I'm given a graph so
essentially I need to generate this
noise I Eddie but let me first pre
generate these decisions and let me show
which edges act by this destruction
right by by crosses right like for
example right so you generate a random
ID to Delta process right and and these
are you know this is the these are the
links that you destroyed right okay so
now so it's easy to see that ok
conditioned on the event right so
suppose that actually ok so let me write
it rigorously so let's eat
let e be event that crosses crosses
disconnect this correct root X 0 from
infinity ok so then on this event write
X 0 is independent is independent of X
right of let's say ok of of X infinity
right of the infinite layer right of X
far away or let or more rigorous I mean
you can put approximately independent
right for all K greater than K 0 K maybe
it's random right so if the sequence of
destructions is so dense that it
disconnects every single path of route
to the bottom right and there is no way
information about X 0 can trickle 2 to
the far away layer right ok so then then
what you can do is you can just say well
ok so what's the price so if I have
bounded degree D layer right so what's
the probability at all edges are erased
here right it's at most right so so with
probability probability greater than 2
delta x lk d right all edges will be
erased right so now what you can do is
you can just say ok
don't don't tell me this was not copied
okay so this was the action of the
erasure channel so this is from some far
from some long-forgotten program all
right so for the next talk we need to
put it back I'll put it back yeah all
right so anyway so right so now if right
so if some of to Delta M cell Kady is
infinite right
then by Borel Cantelli Cantelli
probability of the event e is 1 where is
the event that you disconnected
everything right so this immediately
tells you that if layers grow you know
with with the size logarithmic then you
know with probability 1 you kill all the
edges at some point okay so so what can
we what can we say on the positive side
ok so on the positive side we can
actually say that this is tight indeed
for any super for any logarithmic growth
with large enough constant there exists
Lag jority okay so right so theorem is
the following
we're a needy actually let me not say
for anything let's just say for D in
equals three I want to discuss the case
of of input of in degree three the
following is true first if L K is
greater than C 1 Delta coma well C 1
Delta K and Delta the crossover
probabilities between 0 & 1 sixth then
then let me let me say what happens then
expectation over graph probability East
are okay right so limit as K goes to
infinity is less than 1/2 okay so what
is expectation over J I will explain it
in a second now conversely if L K is
sub-exponential the e1 of Delta XK and
Delta is between 1 6 and 1/2 then
expectation of G of PE star comma K
converges to one half okay so so what is
G so our G right so G is a random dag
process the random dag okay so how do we
generate it so okay so notice that
so we fix the sequence of layer sizes
right you fix the sequence of layer
sizes you tell me how fast you want your
layers to grow and and then I will
generate a graph as for also so I put
this these nodes right whose number you
already prescribed to me right and then
I will add I will randomly draw three of
these edges because my in degree is 3
right and connect them randomly to do
two different folks upstairs so this is
my right so this generates a random
graph and what I'm saying is that uh
yeah and of course I need to tell you
what the processing functions are right
so all the processing functions are just
majority so all right so Oh F I J's are
just majority ok so all right so how do
you prove this this is not very hard
again I can I can just tell you one one
interesting trick how to do it and
that's it
oh by the way so we originally thought
of this construction random done as just
for answering the question about the
speed of growth of layer sizes but then
actually so people started pointing out
that maybe this is actually relevant by
itself and perhaps even more relevant by
itself than the regular grid why because
this can tell you about you know
spreading of information complicated
grids write something like you know
graph like facebook graph I don't know
something right so which which it
doesn't look like you know for
three-dimensional regular green okay so
alright so how do you prove this okay so
the proof is actually very very easy
why because you can check that if you
define Sigma K minus 1 to be fraction
once layer minus 1 okay so then now I'm
thinking about joint randomness right so
I have two sources of randomness one
source of randomness is I fix x0 right
to be for example 0 right and one
randomness is the noise and the other
random this is generating of the graph
right so conditioned on everything above
a certain level above K minus 1 right so
then the interesting thing is that XK
comma i all of these guys are
distributed according Bernoulli
conditioned on on everything up until
layer K minus 1 so this guys are
Bernoulli iid G Delta Sigma K minus 1
what is G Delta so G Delta sub P is a
very nice function it's a it's a
probability that majority of X 1 plus Z
1 X 2 plus Z 2 X 3 plus Z 3 is equal to
1 where the eyes are
iid Bernoulli Delta oh this is 2 right
Delta and Excise are IAD Bernoulli P and
in particular right so because this XK I
so why they ran that why they iid
independent because right this is this
process of generating edges is
independent between right so that's
that's why the random graphs are so easy
to analyze right because they completely
decouple the dynamics of twedge Aysen
sides and that's exactly why it's so
hard to analyze the grid happen ok so
right and because they are IID and there
are lots of them right the the average
magnetization at the k flare at the case
layer right by law of large numbers is
approximately equal with high
probability this G Delta of Sigma K
minus 1 so essentially the average
magnetization is a non random has a non
random evolution right corresponding to
the iterative application of this
function G now the only question is how
does she look like right so we have
these iterations right okay so it turns
out to look like this
so if Delta is less than one-sixth then
right zero one zero one okay so it looks
like this
it's symmetric around so it has a center
of symmetry at at point 1/2 1/2 right
and and otherwise so you can see that
for Delta less than one-sixth it has
three fixed points so if you start if
your initial bit is zero right so you
start here and then you you slowly grow
up right so let's say right so let's
let's bend it a little bit it's actually
convex concave but okay right so you
start from zero and then you do this
kind of progression of the situation's
right and you always grow up to to this
fixed point and that if you start at one
then you then you do these iterations
right and you come to this fixed point
so because of this you never so if the
original bit was zero then average
magnetization is great as is around this
value and if you start from one sorry if
your son young sir average magnetization
completely tells you yes it tells you
the answer and on the other hand for
Delta greater than one six right so if
Delta is greater than one-sixth and this
G del this G of P function has only one
fixed point looks like this
for this reason so zeros and ones become
merged they are exactly IAD oh yeah I
forgot to say that we actually allow
double edges yeah so so it's completely
fine if sometimes you have right so this
is yeah no yeah then then it would be a
little bit Messier but like this
the same percolation I don't know what a
bootstrap percolation oh yeah yeah right
yes yes yes yes yeah yeah that's exactly
yes yes right right that's a boot right
right yes that's that's this kind of
percolation on the random graph yeah so
it's very easy to analyze yes okay so
yes but for converse you can be smarter
yes so know this we don't know okay so
this is a good question so yeah so you
see so the way I put it here right so as
you said so the bootstrap percolation
the threshold is very easy to analyze
right here so that's but the thing is
maybe right if so the actual so let me
finish by saying one open question right
so okay so this kind of settles
everything in this random so there are
two open questions one is D randomized
the construction right to come up with
some weaker condition like is some kind
of expansion sufficient to just prove
this and the second more important
question is the following so you see so
you can use some general information
theory tricks to show that for if 1
minus 2 Delta squared times D is less
than 1 then no matter how you pick those
smart functions you will always die out
so this is right so this for every
choice of for every choice fi J's which
can depend on the graph right you first
generate the graph then you scratch your
head you look at this right you do say
so ok and this gives you the threshold
Delta which is point 21 or something
like this right and this is 0.17 right
so between point 1 7 and point 21 we
don't know if there exists so so that's
but there is hole because yeah I forgot
to say that this exact iteration appears
in von Neumann reliable circuit stuff
and and they're actually Hayek and
Weller
show that one six is a sharp threshold
but we have some difference and some
some differences here okay anyway so as
I expected I don't have time to say
anything about regular grades but what
we proved is we proved it and NAND and
soar processing doesn't work that's the
summary but it doesn't invalidate the
chance that right so that maybe there is
a smart space dependent choice of
processing functions which will work so
this I don't know
yeah all right so thank you
[Applause]